happy 500,000 subscriber day that's
right today hit 5 2000 subscribers I'm
really excited so I wanted to celebrate
so I bought myself a cake and while I
was in the checkout line the guy was
like hey ma'am I just wanted to let you
know that you bought an extra zero for
your 50 yeah so that I had to explain to
him middle it's five hundred thousand
blah blah blah anyway long story short
it was an awkward conversation to have
always an awkward conversation you tell
someone you make videos on the internet
thank you guys so much for all of your
support the past couple years I just
wanted to thank you guys so much for
watching my videos um I I love making
them it's so much fun and there's
something that I've always wanted to do
I've always wanted to smash a cake in
someone's face or have one smashed in my
face so I'm gonna smash this cake in my
face just Oliver personally take this
Kansas out because that was not very fun
[Music]
wow that was a lot less exciting than I
thought it was gonna be
[Music]
Oh